the level of AI technological progress
that we could expect five years from now
is basically unimagined
point in time
possibly can do the job that I'm doing
there's no question artificial
intelligence will remake the workplace
AI will replace our jobs
this is the most ridiculous statement
I've ever heard ever since chat GPT came
out there's been this General fear that
AI will replace everyone's jobs and that
all of our skills will suddenly become
completely useless and it's not
surprising why people think this for one
people have seen these tools in action
firsthand they've seen realistic photos
spawning out of denir 3000 word essays
being typed out in 30 seconds and
hundreds of lines of code being drafted
up like it's nothing
at the same time we also have all these
articles that are like AI will replace
47 of all U.S jobs within the next 20
years or AI is set to replace 300
million jobs or AI could replace up to 8
in 10 jobs expert says and it's not just
journalists and media organizations who
are making these bold claims either we
have valedictorians from the most elite
colleges and CEOs of the biggest tech
companies that are all propagating this
notion Elon for example has been
claiming that while all need Universal
basic income because robots will take
all our jobs meanwhile Sundar piche has
been preaching that AI could be more
profound than fire or electricity but
you want to know a secret
Sunder has been saying the exact same
thing for over five years now that's
just his go-to statement when he's
pitching the importance and impact of
Google's AI also remember that study
that was suggesting that 47 of all U.S
jobs will be replaced by AI within the
next 20 years well that study was
published 10 years ago so theoretically
we should already be feeling the pain
yet unemployment is still at the near
all-time lows despite recession fears
High inflation High interest rates and
apparently AI taking over
and the reason is already is AI is not
going to leave all of his jobless
relying on some sort of Ubi from the
government because AI will not be
replacing the value of humans
let me explain
[Music]
to understand why AI doesn't stand a
chance all we have to do is look back at
history in fact we can rewind it 12 000
years to the year 10 000 BC this
probably feels like forever ago but in
the context of human development
it's actually extremely recent modern
humans are thought to have come about
sometime within the past 200 to 300 000
years so 10 000 BC is part of the most
recent five percent of human history up
until this point the life of the average
human was pretty simple virtually every
single human spent the vast majority of
their time on Survival they would hunt
for Animals gather berries and water
create weapons using rocks and sticks
and ignite fires to keep them warm and
cook food basically all of their time
was just spent on Survival but somehow
around the same time some idiots around
the world figured out that if you put a
seed into the ground pour some water on
it and give it some time you could
produce food on demand now imagine if
these Nomads were like bro if we could
just kill this agriculture thing man no
one would have to work anymore
especially if we got good at it imagine
if just one percent of the population
could make enough food for everyone
then we could all just sit around and
never have to worry about survival again
oh
wait that's exactly how it is today
most people in Western countries that
never have to worry about food but
98.7 of Americans are not unemployed in
fact it's the other way around the
people who produce all of our food are
usually the least paid the least
respected and the least valued even
though they often work the longest the
hardest and are essential to our
survival now theoretically speaking we
could have made that Nomad dream a
reality we could have had some sort of
system where all of us only have to work
like one week every year on the fields
the rest of the time we could just sit
in our huts and have food handed to us
thinking back this did start to happen
as the efficiency of Agriculture
skyrocketed the amount of free time
people had also skyrocketed but people
didn't just opt to sit around instead
they started mastering crafts they be
James killed Bakers Carpenters butchers
soldiers stonemasons and tailors we
spent our time building entire cities
with hundreds of roles jobs and
mechanics all centered around these
agricultural hubs and agriculture is
just one example such shifts have
occurred thousands of times during human
history during the Advent of concrete
electricity light bulbs telephones
locomotives cars planes drugs highways
vaccines computer smartphones the
internet and who knows what else I mean
just think about this sixty percent of
all workers are currently in occupations
that did not even exist in 1940. let me
phrase that in a different way the
majority of all working people are
working at jobs that did not even exist
a single lifetime ago so how in the
world is the Advent of AI any different
from what we've already been doing over
the past 12 000 years well some would
argue that it's the speed of AI progress
that makes it so dangerous not only will
AI replace low-level factory jobs or
cashier jobs but it'll also replace
White Collar jobs like doctors lawyers
and engineers and to this I once again
call BS let me explain
people often like to claim that it's the
speed of AI advancement that makes it so
disruptive but this too is easily
disprovable yes AI is advancing faster
than anything we've seen before but
guess what
so did every other revolutionary
technology that's kind of why it's
revolutionary it took agriculture 10 000
years to catch on but it only took
thousands of years for cities to catch
on it only took hundreds of years for
electricity only decades for Tech and
only years for smartphones so it's only
natural that AI is able to catch on
within months but really it's not even
that fast researchers predict that ai's
computational power will double every 6
to 10 months but this isn't even all
that crazy when you consider Moore's Law
back in 1965 Gordon Moore the eventual
founder of Intel predicted that the
number of transistors on integrated
circuits will double every single year
and he was spot on over the next 10
years the number of transistors and
microchips jumped from a few hundred to
tens of thousands but after this fast
initial jump Gordon would actually
revise his prediction addiction down as
progress larger transistor is doubling
every two years which has largely held
true over the past 50 years or so
So objectively speaking the intelligence
of tech was advancing the fastest back
in the late 60s and early 70s but if you
extrapolated that to argue that this
would be the fastest period of tech
adoption you would have been completely
wrong
Microsoft and Apple weren't even a thing
yet and there were still decades still
Google and Facebook would even be
founded really it wasn't until the 2000s
and especially after the launch of the
iPhone that Tech adoption actually
became ubiquitous now this isn't to say
that it'll take decades for AI to become
ubiquitous it's obviously advancing into
being adopted faster than computers but
it's still naturally going to take time
the thing to remember is that with each
and every one of these revolutionary
introductions it's humans who are
creating and propagating these changes
so naturally these changes will be
limited by the laws of supply and demand
just because you make a great AI doesn't
mean that it'll be instantly adopted
it'll only be adopted when there is a
demand for it and there will only be a
demand for it when the technology and a
large portion of society are ready for
it
so this time is not different it never
is in fact I'd wager that AI will
actually catch on much slower than you
might expect and the best example of
this is the field automation of
factories
before everyone was worried about AI
taking over why color jobs people were
scared about automation taking over
factory jobs and this makes sense given
that back in 1979 Factory employment was
at an all-time high
19.6 million Americans worked factory
jobs so fancy robot arms and assembly
lines obviously made them feel uneasy
and these fears were Justified factory
jobs did indeed decline by 35
over the next 40 years in other words
all of these crazy computer chips that
went from a thousand transistors to 50
billion transistors weren't even able to
eliminate half of factory jobs over the
next 40 years they weren't even
eliminating one percent per year and
that's not even accounting for all of
the factory jobs that were shipped
overseas as opposed to being replaced by
robots
the number one reason for this is that
Robots Suck at handling edge cases our
AI Overlord Elon is actually the most
familiar with this as he was nearly
driven into bankruptcy because of it you
see as a staunch Ai and automation
supporter I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that Elon tried to
create a completely automated Tesla
Factory he hired the best software and
AI Engineers on the planet sunk billions
of dollars into building his Grand
gigafactory and had hundreds of
thousands of people waiting to receive
their model 3s
theoretically all he had to do was press
the go button on the factory deliver a
bunch of cars and make a crap ton of
money easy right well all of this
changed when he actually pressed the Go
Button there's really no Pleasant way to
put this the reality was that his
automated Factory was absolute trash one
small misalignment in the sheets of
metal and the robots couldn't screw in
the bolt one small misalignment in the
paint job and the robot would paint the
window such matters are trivial for
humans to handle but for robots such
matters made them completely ineffective
Elon found himself constantly stopping
the production line to fix all the
errors that these robots were causing
this destroyed the productivity of
factories leading to Tesla burning
billions of dollars and getting single
digit weeks away from bankruptcy do you
know how Tesla recovered from this
manufacturing hell
well everyone including the tech guys
had to work on the factory line and work
100 plus hours every week to just get
Tesla to stop burning money AKA Tesla
had to de-automate their Factory and
Elon would end up admitting yes
excessive automation at Tesla was a
mistake to be precise my mistake humans
are underrated
if this is the case with simple
repetitive Factory automation how in the
world is it realistic to assume that AI
can just automate software engineering
just because it can write algorithms or
solve a hard leak code problems it
really makes no sense at all the vast
majority of a software engineer's time
is not spent on doing the fun obvious
stuff
in fact the fun obvious stuff takes no
time at all the vast majority of time is
spent on doing the boring but essential
stuff how do we handle all of these
different errors how do we scale this
code seamlessly how do we address all
these edge cases this is precisely where
Engineers spend their time and this is
precisely what AI cannot do I mean just
look at Tesla autopilot they were able
to get Lane assist on highways working
extremely fast but getting it to work
everywhere else is proving to be
extremely difficult now with that being
said it would also be stupid to think
that AI won't affect software
engineering at all it absolutely will
but we're talking about a slow shift
away like with manufacturing as opposed
to something that just transpires
overnight just because GPT has 100
accuracy on lead code and this brings us
into the last argument regarding AI
replacing jobs which is that it'll
replace more jobs than it creates
the idea that AI will take away more
jobs than it creates is really quite
stupid because AI nor any new technology
is a zero-sum game and it's quite
limiting to look at it from that
perspective take the internet for
example in the early days the internet
was largely used for research purposes
if people thought that the internet
would take away jobs just because it
would put a lot of libraries out of
business and in return only give a
thousand jobs to coders obviously that
statement is laughable today but is it
really that far-fetched back in the day
40 years ago no one would have been able
to Fathom the idea of a multi-hundred
billion dollar social media companies
e-commerce platforms Cloud providers
database Solutions streaming Giants
fintech offerings food delivery ride
sharing online booking Services the list
really goes on forever it'll be the
exact same way with AI
from our current position we can only
Envision how AI will disrupt the jobs
and careers that we already know we have
no chance of even conceptualizing all of
the jobs and careers that AI will create
15 years ago it wasn't even possible to
make money as an influencer today being
a YouTuber is the number one dream job
in America also not only did Tech create
a bunch of jobs but it created the new
first class
think about all of the richest people in
the world their owners of tech companies
Executives of debt companies employees
of tech companies partners of tech
companies Affiliates of tech companies
investors of tech companies and so on
honestly if you weren't involved in Tech
within the past 20 years you were
probably left behind and it's no wonder
why these companies are able to create
value faster and at larger skills than
ever before this will only be a tour
with AI as AI makes work magnitudes more
efficient so not only will AI not make
everyone jobless hobos but it'll
actually create an unprecedented number
of insanely high-paying jobs along with
hundreds of trillionaires because the
only way that it plays out in any other
way is if humans fundamentally change
if humans fundamentally change and
somehow become satisfied with what we
already have the current Tech we have
the current economy we have in the
current society that we have
as long as people are always striving
for more and more you can rest assured
that will never end up in some sort of
AI dystopia where robots do everything
and humans do nothing there will always
be something for us to do and if there
isn't you can be sure as hell that will
make something for us to do and that
that's why the idea of AI replacing
everyone's jobs is simply ridiculous
AI content for example is already
rooting YouTube if you want to learn
more check out this video but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]